♪♪
(Vocalizing)
Pete Townshend:
I could see this new
revolution coming.
Pete Townshend:
It was an anticipation of the
idea that everything would go wrong,
Pete Townshend:
but that music would prevail.
♪Mother mother♪
Jimmy Iovine:
1971. I don't think the music
was a reflection of the times as much as
the music  also caused the
times.
♪♪Brother brother brother♪
Phillip Zimbardo:
It was an incredibly tumultuous
year...
♪♪
Phillip Zimbardo:
Politically, socially,
musically.
I think that music reflects the
stage that the society's in.
Chrissy Hynde:
All these bands were making
music referring to protests and the Vietnam war.
Chrissy Hynde:
That was our language.
I would to like to say something
that hasn't been said so much,
you know.
(Protest chants)
Peter Tatchell:
1971 was a year of revolution
and consciousness.
♪Oh, what's going on♪
♪(What's going on)♪
Chrissy Hynde:
We were fueled by this amazing
music that everyone was making.
♪I'll tell you, what's going on♪
Chrissy Hynde:
It was articulating everything
you're seeing and feeling.
♪♪
(Vocalizing)
You know, we have survived
everything that's gone down and
come out stronger.
♪♪
(Vocalizing)
Marvin Gaye:
I think this is my cross to
bare.
Marvin Gaye:
I'm the messenger.
Graham Nash:
We thought that music could
change the world.
♪♪
I don't think you really really
have a new thing until you've got
new music.
♪We'll be fighting in the
streets♪
Robert Greenfield:
The peace and flowers, love
thing, was over.
Brian Jackson:
I wasn't a soldier, I was a
musician.
Brian Jackson:
How could they use my music to
help change things?
All power to the people.
♪I'll tip my hat to the new
constitution♪
Elton John:
I don't think you'll ever see a
creative burst like that musically, ever again.
Robert Greenfield:
These were not just players,
they were cultural icons.
We had come through something.
If we could this far, we could get
further.
Tony Visconti:
They took this on and things
changed.
♪♪
Man:
The music...
♪♪
Man:
Was not a soundtrack.
♪♪
Man:
It was much more than that.
♪♪
(Vocalizing)